salut à tous alors aujourd'hui je suis
de retour au point où j'ai fait le
revolver 1851 avec le pirate a donc
aujourd'hui on n'est que deux ans on va
essayer de retrouver ce qui se cache
encore sous ce pont et faire le port qui
à côté c'est parti pour la vidéo à ya
des gens qui sont passés d'accord pour
ça qu'il ne reste pas grand chose alors
de pêche coule toujours bien un petit
l'heure où le film
donc du plastique
ok rasta je crois que j'ai quelque chose
tu es prêt non
bon bah c'est très propre bon ben je
vais aller faire le port cas plus loin
donc il n'y avait pas grand chose sous
le pont maintenant on va essayer au
niveau du port donc là je pense que
c'est un an passant de tennis
aurore ce que ça donne je pense qu'il
peut avoir plein d'outils sont tombés et
quelque chose
hockey amicale entendeur donc ici ça n'a
pas été fait vraisemblablement c'est
plutôt logique
un lot continue à la marque au jeu sans
eau non même pas ok tu me vole pas mais
trouva rien une belle fourchette superbe
et un clic et deux péniches
[Musique]
oh qu'est ce que c'est que tout ça un
cutter ah ah ah non c'est un cutter et
raccords hydrauliques sympa à chercher
à la police municipale m'en faut dire
que j'ai arrêté de péché parce qu on est
dans l'aude c'est interdit dans l'aude
alors continue au des grelots ballon et
nike s'est cassé tu vas les grelots
rasta voilà ça tu vas faire du bruit
maintenant du tout univers à j'ai
quelque chose
et oui une cuillère super regarde je
prends vraiment quelque chose et quelque
chose oh oh oh c'est quoi ça oh oh oh oh
oh oh c'est bon ça il a encore n'en
dirai ya six essais ça c'est la
trouvaille
et avec ça une fourchette hop là un
autre tant d'heures outch super j'ai
réussi à avoir une partie du gros truc
je crois
d'accord ok web
effectivement c'est une plaque une
plaque et un temps de en tout cas sympa
ce couteau la preuve que même dans les
ports on peut trouver des armes on va
dire ainsi celle là elle est juste tombé
sûrement du bateau aux eaux des outils
ouais super leur de pêche ça c'est un
genre de vieux tournevis tordu une pince
à plat alors qu'est-ce qu'on sort de
beau ici à pompe pense que c'est une
constante et pompes sympa
singer dessus
non non non non bon ok
tout est bloqué je fais ok donc quand on
est bloqué on change lang s'est plaint
que j'ai eu c'est désenvaser au oui
qu'est-ce que c'est assez lourd c'est
ultra lourd d'accord ok encore entendeur
eh ben quatre ou cinquième de journée à
ce sujet les cas c'est bien dommage ou
une pince nickel
donc là j'ai trouvé quelque chose de
conséquent quelques kilos
lorsque c'est au bout
d'accord on espère un coup tout çà ou là
il est mort au nom pas dommage vieux
couteau alors il vient morts
[Musique]
accordons sympa
dernier lors de la journée at on dit ça
qu'est ce que ça peut être
qu'est ce que c'est au faux
un piquet de péniches très original et
un couteau crioc qui n'est pas vendu
note du coup on mais voilà cette vidéo
touche à sa fin donc pour nous deux a un
peu tiqué ce taper chez il n'a pas pêché
grand chose mais en tout cas il a été
très sage donc je vais de ramener la
pêche c'est bien à bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo qui enverra encore plus
douloureux